- All the best foods are
eaten with your hands.
- Yeah.
- Everyone knows that, and
people who don't know that
are wrong.
(bright calypso music)
- [Man] I've never had Nigerian
food, I've always wanted
to try it and I'm excited.
(bright calypso music)
- This meat's a little
chewy which I really like.
- Tastes like spaghetti.
- It does!
Like, better than spaghetti.
- It's like if sweet
potato fries had a cousin
and that cousin was better.
(light music)
- The lady back here
wonderfully explained that it's
very customary to do this which
makes sense because you're
eating from your hand.
- Okay, you're a pro.
- I just cheated, I
watched other people do it.
- A lot of times in America
we get so used to just, like,
fork and knives kind of
shoving it into your mouth
all the time, whereas, this
is more of like a full-on
experience.
- All the best foods are
eaten with your hands.
Is there a fishiness I detect?
- A little, I get that too.
- It's like tangy, sharp,
it tastes like tofu-ish.
- Kind of just like really
starchy, overcooked rice
in like a mashed potato, but
with this together it has
so much more flavor.
- I love all meats on sticks.
I've never had a meat
on stick I didn't like.
- It's like a powdery
flavor on the outside.
Very beef jerky-ish also.
- It's one of those things
where it's, it is hot,
but as you keep eating it
you just kind of burn off
your feelers a bit so
it's easier to eat it.
- [Man] It's like
addicting, like hot Cheetos.
- Mmm-hmm, Mmm-hmm.
This is really opening up my sinuses.
It snapped me out of my food coma.
(big band music)
- [Man] It's a lot of like,
it's like salty and spicy.
- Like the Midwestern in me
wants to get like a big ass roll
and just dunk it.
- I'm not a big seafood guy
but this is like a good level
of fishiness.
- I also can tell that they
roasted the peppers beforehand
which is really great.
Give it some great, deep flavor.
- I'm sweating.
- Wow.
It like hits you in a wave of heat.
- I can't even speak.
- It's kind of comforting,
like comforting food.
- It's for sure comforting, yeah.
- [Woman] This was delicious.
I had a great time eating all
that and I wish it was more
mainstream so I can eat
that jollof rice anywhere.
It was so good.
- A lot of our cultures around the world,
especially foodwise, have stemmed
from there and I feel like
it's just been a great experience
that we're missing out on.
(bright calypso music)